alors l'abominable homme de Rungis a une
histoire avec une personnalité qui est
venue sur ce plateau il y a pas
longtemps
même genre la vérité il dit n'importe
quoi même genre non non il dit n'importe
quoi
en dehors du plateau et je le et voilà
fake news voilà fake
tu m'aurais pas mangé
tout hein
non après si vous voulez des trucs de
télé-réalité tout ça je peux y aller non
si vous voulez j'y vais moi Guillaume il
parle moi je peux y aller sur la télé
quoi
tu penses à quoi Guillaume mais il est
beaucoup dans la téléréalité
les gens connus tu vois beaucoup de gens
connus c'est quoi les sujets aujourd'hui
là
alors
moi j'ai pas dit de la calomnie moi je
dis des choses vrai tu me tires dessus
je te tire dessus me compare de d'une
certaine marchand arrête
de millionnaire
[Applaudissements]
maintenant on fait comme vous voulez
contre ces accusations et c'est pas
parce que Raymond a une aventure avec
Cindy Lopes
[Applaudissements]
maintenant deux colonnes je vais écrire
Jean-Mi Guillaume
je vais faire c'est toi qui a commencé
avec tes histoires de Goten là je vais
faire deux colonnes maintenant celui qui
me tire dessus je tire pour de vrai avec
des dossiers récents je demande à Siri
les gens ils viennent pour voir touche
pas mon poste pour voir de la lessive
comme ça
je vais vous dire la vérité Cindy je
l'adore
de l'émission et je peux attester
tu retrouves la raison j'aimerais
Guillaume retrouve la raison merci à
tous Voilà salut débat et on fait
l'émission maintenant
merci ça c'est fou non je te regarde
j'apprécie beaucoup sur son vérifier
alors IBA aurait manqué ça me ferait
beaucoup de peine et Marjolaine c'est
vrai bien sûr que c'est vrai allez on
passe
s'il vous plaît c'est moi
[Rires]